hi I'm doing thorough surveillance
obscura welcome back to the YouTube
channel in case you've forgotten who I
am what now obscure it is what we're all
doing here let me give you a quick
refresher I'm Dylan Alice obscura is an
organization dedicated to the world's
hidden wonders we've been growing our
database of fifteen thousand places all
over the world
we also share incredible foods unusual
dishes and ingredients we are running
events all over the country we are
taking trips all over the world and on
top of all of that we are gonna be
adding a ton of new video incredible
series to this YouTube channel we are
gonna be doing more than just 100
wonders which was the main video
previously we are gonna be giving you a
series about collectors people who have
unbelievable objects in their home
basements Barb's we're gonna be doing a
series of an incredible artists like a
miniature
artist who builds little versions of
buildings about to be torn down
unbelievable skill and grasp agenda
we're gonna do food videos about how to
make the world's bounciest meatball it
is so incredibly bouncy you would not
believe how bouncy it is so for all of
you who love the 100 wonder series
you're gonna see me you're gonna get
videos about places but you're gonna
meet new people other members of the
atmosphere a team and all of its gonna
live here on this YouTube channel we've
already put some of these videos up on
the channel so I would love it if you
wanted to go check those out leave us a
comment and let us know you think and
we're gonna be publishing a new video
every Tuesday so set the little Bell
thing let you know you can subscribe
here and if you are confused about what
I am talking about
you should go at the website here Alice
obscura comm you can see our trips
events stories places database
everything